for some of you that are like what is
man I haven't downloaded it yet let me
tell you what's going on with man what
would you pay to get a response from
somebody you're dming just think about
that I you know I get tens of thousands
of messages on Instagram or LinkedIn I
don't get back to people because I can't
but we wanted to find a way to have an
incentive for the individual to get back
to you and at the same time for you to
be able to get a question you want to
get answered by people that's why we
launched man years
ago I had a lawyer that charged me uh
for a 7 minute call 30 minutes pissed me
off I said why are you charging me 30
minutes he says minutes roll up I said
no they don't it was a 7-minute call I
said one day I'm going to build an app
to get to pay people by the minute not
roll up and that's exactly what man man
does